well mark ira guys congratulations you
are moving forward in the third and
final round of this competition in this
round you're going back to your home
forges to battle it out for four days
building an iconic weapon from history
we want you to build
this the serrated indian saber
the serrated indian saber traces its
origins back to 18th century india the
deadly weapon features a long curved
blade with serrated edges designed to
intimidate enemies and penetrate deep
into the thick leather armor worn by
infantry and cavalry forces of the time
this blade played an important role as
the sword used by indian forces during
the bloody 1857 uprising against british
rule known as the sapoi mutant
without further ado guys good luck we
will see you in four days
brother
[Music]
myra housework from a western slope of
colorado i've been a blacksmith now for
over 20 years
when i was eight years old i developed a
bone tumor and it grew real fast and
then stopped
it doesn't affect me my eyes work really
well but that's not really what i'm here
to talk about i'm here to show you what
i can do with a piece of hot steel it's
a really lightweight blade so i think
we'll just do solid steel there's 99
teeth to do so it's going to take a
little while
i'm worried about the spacing and the
angle in which they go in it's one of my
biggest concerns on the entire build
lots of things can go wrong with the
quench but let's go for it
it's perfectly straight
let's finish it up
we're going to use a black walnut for
the handle and then on the top it's
going to be capped with a silicone
bronze
i want to wrap the handle with a little
bit of copper twisted wire it looks good
finished sanding
and then a finished sharpening
i'm nervous but hopefully it holds up
i think that's it
[Music]
my name is mark smith i'm from china
spring texas i'm a design engineer for a
local bank equipment manufacturer
season three of fortune fire i started
watching it about that time i weighed
close to 400 pounds fortune fire was a
driver to get more healthy i lost about
150 pounds from blade smithing and
life is good
it's taking more time than i anticipated
to get the material down to the thinness
that i want
and then we'll be ready to go and start
doing the features of the saber
fitting the guard i have to be careful
if i remove too much material off the
inside of the guard there's going to be
big gaps it's not going to fit tight
and if it doesn't i'm probably going to
redo the guard
it should be fine it should be okay
so i'm quenching the blade
today i don't think i get it any
straighter than that
there's no cracks and everything's
looking pretty good right now i dyed the
epoxy gold because it looks cool and
it's close to
the bronze guard i think it has a nice
touch to it
winning this competition would be like
winning the super bowl
it's about showing that
forgetting fire is tearing my life
around and giving me the skills
to do this
basements welcome to the dynamic heel
test
mark your first you ready for this
blade's ready
all right mark to talk about your weapon
here your handle is a little bit on the
rounded side but the saving grace is
this flare that you have there it
allowed me to get my hand in here and
it's locked in between your guard
and your pummel good on that
now you did pick up
one
small chip where it cut the bone
but other than that
it'll kill thank you
i know your turn are you ready i'm ready
so
[Music]
all right ira first up the slices into
this ballistics dummy thrusting and
using the teeth i can really feel
everything on the blade but what's more
important is the wheel the ability of
this weapon it's so nice and light and i
can control every move
overall sir your indian serrated saber
you will kill
all right gentlemen welcome to our
dynamic strength test sticking with our
sheet metal theme our sheet metal chop
and bag slice
so mark you're up first you ready she's
got this but i might need a hug
so
all right mark right off your blade is
still
in the shape it came in
felt good cutting it's a little on the
forward heavy side i would have seen
that balance just a little bit further
back but it didn't affect the cuts at
all so good job
ready to play ira
not really
[Laughter]
i am
[Music]
[Music]
so ira
first off
the shape and scale of this is really
beautiful the way it just flows from one
point to the other the taper really
really nice he took one chip in the
blade right here
but other than that this is still i'm
not going to run my finger down this
blade it's still short well done
thank you
well gentlemen in the first two rounds
of this competition you both proved your
worth by making knives out of sheet
metal and in this final round you both
knocked it out of the park with the most
intricate blades i've seen in a long
time but in this competition only one of
you can take home the title and a check
for ten thousand dollars but our judges
did agree
that today's fortune fire champion is
ira congratulations i'm mark
unfortunately at this point i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor been a tremendous pleasure
thank you job mark
i'm happy that it came down to such
details i think any other competition i
could have gotten on the winner
well ira congratulations sir you are the
newest fortune fire champion and you
just received a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations
just one forging fire it feels pretty
awesome that's a beautiful example of
that weapon i think you nailed it well
thank you the whole experience has been
super fun
for the stressful part of building the
first knife playing with the coal iron
press i think that's where the money's
going
you